[SPEAKER_04]: So, you guys do a long rest sleeping through the morning of the 7th of Whale Sun and awaken at 7 a.m. on the 7th of Whale Sun as the sun rises over the ocean to the east.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, let's get on the move.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's move.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, I wanted to tell them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, so you have an hour to talk as you finish your long rest, but let's go ahead and role play that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, Merrick and I are in agreement on why we were sent here, was to get the information from what Owen was doing and
[SPEAKER_03]: What's going on at Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_03]: And what's going on at Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_03]: You found out way beyond what we thought we could get, which is phenomenal.
[SPEAKER_03]: We've got to go back.
[SPEAKER_03]: We've got to report that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Most likely, introduce you to Jameis.
[SPEAKER_03]: Jameis is way up.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's never, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Never had a chance to interact with him.
[SPEAKER_04]: In fact, the biggest lord he's ever actually talked to was
[SPEAKER_03]: Lord Fairwin, my buddy, might have to bring you in, because I believe...
[SPEAKER_03]: He's going to want to hear it firsthand and be able to ask the questions directly, knowing Seamus.
[SPEAKER_03]: With that being said, we need to get back to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_03]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_03]: That is our main concern.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know you want to bring supplies, but the bigger goal of this is to get the Monmurgian Navy to come in and break this and take the supplies back.
[SPEAKER_03]: But the point is, we do that, there's dragons.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not necessarily.
[SPEAKER_02]: They might be gone right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: How do you... Because if Toli has this artifact you're talking about, and he's going somewhere to work with a necromancer or...
[SPEAKER_02]: I forget exactly where he's going, but we saw him heading east.
[SPEAKER_02]: We saw him heading east.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fast.
[SPEAKER_00]: He might have taken them.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, they're not there because I know that the turtle dragons are surrounding Kane Toli's
[SPEAKER_00]: Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pallas Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: From anybody.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if they were taking, if Caintoli was going east, the Turtle Dragons would have been right with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I think they are in the middle of the blockage happening between Monmurg and Redshore of that area.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, here, let's map it out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's Redshore.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here are the Dragon Isles.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here is Keoland.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's Kaintoli's Island.
[SPEAKER_04]: You saw him over here two days ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: We could definitely...
[SPEAKER_01]: Without having dragons anywhere.
[SPEAKER_04]: Monmurgian fleet.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: If they're not clouding and doing stuff here like they were before...
[SPEAKER_02]: Isn't there a blockage right there?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think it's all gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: The deal is this.
[SPEAKER_04]: If Kaintoli was here...
[SPEAKER_03]: We have a problem.
[SPEAKER_04]: You saw him this far away, and if he's got him with him a day and a half, two days ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And moving.
[SPEAKER_01]: And moving that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because that ship is fast.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, can you guys get a boat?
[SPEAKER_01]: And get us offshore.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can figure out something.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what we're gonna do.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think we're gonna...
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're telling me the fastest way to get supplies back to the people of Monmurg is to go back to Monmurg and get the Navy to come back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, if the waters are clear, which he can...
[SPEAKER_03]: He can tell and then report that and immediately before Toli gets back, this has to be done quickly.
[SPEAKER_03]: We just need a ship at this point.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then I think we're going to scout this southern part of the island for any type of maybe fishing or something else so we don't have to try to get something through the blockade.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's nothing on this side.
[SPEAKER_03]: But sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: He'll be able to tell.
[SPEAKER_03]: In how much time?
[SPEAKER_02]: We're starting now.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll give you an hour.
[SPEAKER_02]: They come in, you guys are going with me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, because we're all going one place together.
[SPEAKER_03]: If there's a ship, we're going to it, we're going.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can barter passage, we can steal something.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need to get back.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need to move now.
[SPEAKER_02]: I want to head up.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're here.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're right there.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can go down the coast that way.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nothing really over here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Lighthouse.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's go up the ridge, and we're going to walk that way.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: With Merrick leading, you guys walk up onto the ridge and make very good time walking down the edge of the south part of
[SPEAKER_04]: The island.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I have a question for you, Merrick.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to try and detect for turtle dragons using your natural ranger ability?
[SPEAKER_04]: It costs a spell slot, but you can check for dragons within a six mile radius of the area.
[SPEAKER_02]: Check here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Save it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think I want to save it until we find the ship first.
[SPEAKER_04]: How often can he do that?
[SPEAKER_04]: He can do it every time he does a spell slot.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, three spell slots.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two or three.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, I mean, he could check the entire, he could basically check the island all around it if he wanted to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait till we find the ship.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna give us a ship first.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because if there's turtle dragons here...
[SPEAKER_02]: We would have known.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nobody would have been coming in and out.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: If they're intelligent, they can let it.
[SPEAKER_03]: They know what to attack and what not to attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not worried about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's also being controlled right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no way King Toli is guarding Red Shore for any reason.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not worried about it right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's get off this island and let's start going directly back instead of the way we came before.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I will start checking when we go that way.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I mean, we go directly back and they're there.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can see six miles out.
[SPEAKER_02]: If I can be like, oh, there's fucking turtle dragons, we're moving.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're not gonna come off.
[SPEAKER_03]: But they might really not give a shit about a small ship that's six miles away from them, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: If we camp up on them, yeah, that would be a problem, but six miles will be fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: We did sail in between there.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, we went through the Dragon Isles.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's keep moving and let's see what we can find.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright, so you guys spend the early morning walking the coast to the west.
[SPEAKER_04]: Looking down on the city of Redchor with all the ships in it and everything like that.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that's basically where all the people go.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you want to walk all the way down to the end, or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, the castle's down at the end, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: As we're walking, I want to look.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there any fishing going on?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there any ships we can see?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there anything...
[SPEAKER_04]: So as you go this way, this end of the island is pretty much abandoned.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nothing in the ocean out there either that we can see.
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't see any ships out there.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, normally this would be...
[SPEAKER_04]: Whaling ships for... Well, I mean, you would see merchants, you would see a whole bunch of stuff, but it's pretty desolate in that direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: There would normally be stuff out there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Even though there's a huge amount here, and you see those three men-of-war kind of cowling the 50 or so ships here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Other ships are coming in here, being led back in.
[SPEAKER_04]: And as you go, you realize that there are probably two men-of-war up there
[SPEAKER_04]: That are working the lines, bringing them back into this area.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_04]: You roll a wisdom check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Five.
[SPEAKER_02]: Plus four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you guys walk down the coast.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've seen a lot of the ocean.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does the ocean anywhere out there look odd?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I've watched a lot of waves.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do any of the waves look odd out there?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, not really.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, just like odd choppiness or weird happening things out there?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, actually it seems very natural out there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, basically the four of you walk for the first two hours about six miles down the coast and you see the castle on that side and there are
[SPEAKER_04]: You know, like, buildings, dwellings in the middle, but really not for a mile from this strip of land.
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't see any ships or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_04]: It becomes pretty apparent to you all that if you want to get a ship, you're gonna have to go back in the city.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, if we want to head back towards the city, in Folsom you can do some sweet-talking without
[SPEAKER_02]: Fucking it up.
[SPEAKER_03]: Great.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can we see if Owen's ship, can we see that far onto the coast?
[SPEAKER_03]: But that ship is still there.
[SPEAKER_04]: I said we don't take that one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Over here?
[SPEAKER_02]: I said we don't take that one.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, you're too far away to see that one.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's got a big enough ship to where I don't think four people can take a whole ship, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Owen?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it was a tiny old sloop.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, two people could pilot.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I don't think we should take his ship, though.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's probably pretty hot.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well...
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen pulled me aside and said we had a ship for Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_00]: Had a ship for Tyrus, but what we could do is maybe see if that boat cleared up at all.
[SPEAKER_00]: The one that you were taking on board too?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, there was only one Toli on board inside the cabin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take us to it.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's at the end of the dock.
[SPEAKER_02]: With all the merchants and stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I'll get us to the merchant place.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're gonna, I'm gonna try to change my appearance in any way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hope we got cloaks and stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I have my entertainers pack full of costumes?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but it's costumes.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, you can wrap it up as a wizard.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm the only one that's gonna really, really stand out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six-foot-seven, frickin' red-haired dude.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're gonna say it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plate chest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, I'm gonna stand out pretty bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was gonna say, a wizard cloak is gonna look a lot better than that.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I wouldn't do for a Holocaust cloak.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna be able to put a clay nose on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mad Max, he said it looks so nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: How many, uh, costumes do I have in my entertainments pack?
[SPEAKER_00]: Just one, typically?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I mean, you have, like,
[SPEAKER_04]: You can put a mustache on and do things like that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I already have a mustache.
[SPEAKER_04]: I got a full beard.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you have a razor, you can shave off the mustache.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll try to be as inconspicuous as possible.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let those two go find out what's on the boat.
[SPEAKER_01]: The two inconspicuous ones.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you think, Gouge?
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys go find out if the boat's clear?
[SPEAKER_03]: Is it saleable?
[SPEAKER_03]: What?
[SPEAKER_03]: If we got something to go around, that'd be way too long to grab them so they weren't in the city as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Could they pick us up on the other side?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, you guys might have to swim out.
[SPEAKER_04]: But you could navigate around.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think the most dangerous part is getting out of here, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Slipping out.
[SPEAKER_04]: Obviously the best time to do it would be at night.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you guys can recon and go find the boat in the daytime.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or maybe at night, maybe you guys go fly and slip onto it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Clear it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can find a boat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Guests could definitely recon some shit rather than me and him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd say so.
[SPEAKER_01]: Me and Folsom.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, there's four of us they're looking for.
[SPEAKER_03]: If... Well, I assume they're looking for it.
[SPEAKER_03]: We fucked up a couple guys, so they're not going to be happy about that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Whether or not under a higher rule telling them to find us, them themselves will want to find us, so...
[SPEAKER_04]: Now, they probably didn't get a very good look at you.
[SPEAKER_03]: There was a lot of fog, and it was night.
[SPEAKER_03]: And there's enough scoundrels down along the beach.
[SPEAKER_02]: But they did see a big red-headed guy there, though.
[SPEAKER_02]: As long as we're not in an area where shit was happening, we went back to Owen's ship.
[SPEAKER_02]: Probably not the best move.
[SPEAKER_02]: If we go to the city, and if we're going with merchants and stuff, if we're discreet enough...
[SPEAKER_01]: I wouldn't walk into the bar where you guys were.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, we're not going to the bar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep Gouge away from the bar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's walk that, find the merchants, have Folsom do some talking.
[SPEAKER_02]: Find that ship that... Find that ship he's been talking about, and I don't know where he's pulling this information from.
[SPEAKER_01]: But leave me and Folsom up in the woods.
[SPEAKER_01]: You two go find it.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you can tell us where it is, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Leave us up here.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can sail around the other side and signal.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want to swim out to the ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, we're going to bring you through.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're going to go find a ship and come back and then go back again.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think that would be great.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's going to be a lot worse.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think we've got these man-of-war's on you guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: When we come back, it'll be at night and everything else.
[SPEAKER_02]: It'll be a totally different day.
[SPEAKER_02]: He can get us back quick.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, let's do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's walk towards the markets.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so do you want to leave Folsom and Tyrus in the woods?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's go back a direction that's going to be closest to the ship that we're going to try to get to shorten it up, but leave them well hidden beyond their poor stealth skills allowed.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was just a bad bush on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can hide.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we're going to try to get them as close, completely safely, to the spot we're going to to shorten up the trip to go back and forth to grab them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright, so Folsom tries to remember the dock where Owen's ship was.
[SPEAKER_04]: He must do an intelligence check to see how accurate the information is.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's a three.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus?
[SPEAKER_04]: Two.
[SPEAKER_04]: So it's five.
[SPEAKER_04]: So explain.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's Doc, and... You should just probably take me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just find a ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: Any ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did the ship look...
[SPEAKER_04]: It looks exactly like the sloop that you came in on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe a little newer.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, and are there just a lot of those types of sloops around this area?
[SPEAKER_00]: They're pretty common.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, I was just making sure there wasn't anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like we're on our own.
[SPEAKER_04]: It is a Monmurgian sloop, but there's a lot of them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Go find something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Either pay for it or get it.
[SPEAKER_01]: The four of you decide, I guess we all have to go, and you begin walking down into the city.
[SPEAKER_01]: These two start walking, we're staying hidden.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, we gotta take Folsom though, because he didn't remember where the ship was.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, so we all gotta go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do we not want to be in a group of four?
[SPEAKER_03]: Spread out a little bit?
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe... Gouge, you go with Tyrus, I'll go with Folsom.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, there we go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gouge will help me not get too close, not to stay too far away.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gouge, do you want Tyrus to be in a disguise?
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't discuss it.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have a woman's disguise?
[SPEAKER_03]: I can't discuss it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Big red hair.
[SPEAKER_03]: You've got a dress.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just keep moving.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you guys walk down from the thing into the city.
[SPEAKER_04]: Basically walking through, you find a path, Merrick, and you begin walking through the city.
[SPEAKER_04]: You walk past what's kind of a lumber yard.
[SPEAKER_04]: And look down to this side of the docks where you see the rendering vats, which are these large iron vats where they put the whale blubber.
[SPEAKER_04]: The smell here is pretty bad.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're higher up, so you can actually look down on the beach.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's a beach over here.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is littered with whale bones, like just hundreds of carcasses of whale bones, some of them old, some of them not that old.
[SPEAKER_04]: Birds swarm around that area eating the flesh off the whale bodies.
[SPEAKER_04]: And on this side, what seems to be these giant
[SPEAKER_04]: Barrels, which you assume is where the Earl of Redshore keeps his oils from whatever he's done.
[SPEAKER_01]: That could be a diversion.
[SPEAKER_04]: Anyway.
[SPEAKER_01]: At some point.
[SPEAKER_04]: You walk back down to the city.
[SPEAKER_04]: And towards the docks.
[SPEAKER_04]: And there are patrols.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll a wisdom check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who made him?
[SPEAKER_02]: 17 plus 4, 21.
[SPEAKER_04]: There are some Keog Marines walking around and patrolling, which is not something you saw beforehand.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you guys walk down to the area and start looking around the docks.
[SPEAKER_04]: Intelligence check.
[SPEAKER_04]: 15 plus 2.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: It takes you about 30 minutes to get to the area, but you recognize the dock.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: That it is.
[SPEAKER_04]: And basically it's the lantern that's hanging on the thing, even though it's not lit right now, you'll remember what it looked like specifically.
[SPEAKER_04]: The boat's not there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Boat's not there?
[SPEAKER_04]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fuck.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, you've got to say it to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: He dies.
[SPEAKER_00]: The boat's gone.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you mean the boat's gone?
[SPEAKER_02]: The boat.
[SPEAKER_02]: The boat that he knew about is missing.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need to find a new boat.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep, we gotta find a new boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, and we do not want to go back to Bones Boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Noob.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, is there any place in Red Shore that we can go for like
[SPEAKER_00]: To offer Voyage for trading.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there a shop or something?
[SPEAKER_00]: They'll give you passage to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_00]: Where I would say we would take this to Monmurg and travel back with goods.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that would be on black.
[SPEAKER_03]: With your charisma, you might want to talk to one of the new Keoland Marines, if you can, and ask something like, whoa, you know.
[SPEAKER_03]: I gotcha.
[SPEAKER_03]: Why are you guys here?
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Like, I haven't seen you here, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, I'll be back.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, let's keep an eye on you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: You stay here too.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you want to go and pump somebody for information?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'm going to go talk to one of the Keoland Marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: That we haven't seen there before.
[SPEAKER_04]: You haven't seen any of them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you want to go up to a detachment of Keolanders and have a discussion.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, Keolanders are...
[SPEAKER_00]: Where are they located on the map?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, well, here's Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's Salonmoor, which is part of Keoland.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gratzel's way up that way.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the castle here is run by Keoland.
[SPEAKER_04]: The Earl of Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so is there any information you specifically want him to pump the guys out of?
[SPEAKER_04]: We haven't seen them here before.
[SPEAKER_03]: And the ship for the little... Is that concerned, like, what's going on?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, oh, do we need to be concerned?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, fuck.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, the whole place is fucked up, though, so... All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, just say, what brings you guys?
[SPEAKER_04]: I go to the nearest Keoland Marine.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so Folsom walks away, the three of you basically... That's right it is.
[SPEAKER_04]: Keep an eye on him.